As you deposit 00 in a bank at a rate of
10 per what this exactly means we know the
10 per of 100 is 10 so if you deposit 00
with the bank you will get 0 at the end of the
year but what about the second  Year the third
year and so on let's make three columns the year
the
interest and the total interest at the
end of the year let's also make a column for the
amount for each year so we
have four columns now
and remember the amount is the sum of  The
Principal and the
Interest The principal in this case will be the
deposit amount which is
₹1 Let's see what happens in year one because you get an
interest of 10 from the
bank you will get ₹1 as
interest what happens if you keep the money
With the bank for another year you will get another
₹ as
interest and if you keep the ₹1 for one more
year you again get ₹10 as
interest that is simple interest if you keep your
money deposited with the bank you get the same
interest every  Here look at it this way
Your principal will remain in the bank
Draw it at the end of the first year The bank
page You have an interest of ₹10 on this
₹1000000
Principal that
₹10 Ten ₹10 will accrue in the bank until you
withdraw it  Again at the end of the second year the
bank page you get an interest of ₹10 on this
principal
₹10 this will accrue every year
you get an interest on the
principal you
invested Now let's look at the total
interest column if you would have taken the  Money
out in the first year you would have got an
interest of
₹1 and the amount you would have received is
0 Remember amount is the sum of the principal
and the
interest if you would have taken the money out in
the second year you would have  Got 10 + 10 which
is ₹ and amount would equal to ₹ 100 + 20 which equals
₹10 and if you would have taken the money out after
the third year you would have got 10 + 10
+ 10 which is ₹ as interest and an
amount equal  To
₹10 One thing is clear The anchor You keep your
money with the bank The more money you get at the end
of the period So what are the factors that the
amount depends on Look Close It will
depend on the principal and the initial
deposit  More the money you deposit will be more
the final amount it will also depend on the
rate of interest if instead of 10 the bank
offered you 15 the amount you receive will be
higher and of course or the number of years you
deposited the money if any  Of these factors
change the amount you would get will also change this
concept we just say is called simple interest
the interest amount is based on the
original principal only also notice that the
total interest after the second year is
twice the interest of ₹10 and  The interest
after the third year is equal to three times
the interest of ₹1 Can we deduce a
formula to get the total interest after a few
years Let's consider year two we first
looked at the principal which is 100 since the
interest is multiplied by 10  It is by 10 by
100 and since it is the second year we
multiply by two this gives as the
interest in the first year and we
multiply by two to get the total interest after two
years if you solve this you will
get a 20 and similarly  For Year Three the
Total Interest Will Equal 100 * Ba 10 /
100 * 3 This Will Give You 30 So Based on
This Concept We Will Solve an Example
in the Next
[Music]
Video